Alexis is with us in Michigan I Alexis
how are you I'm doing well are you doing
better than I deserve your question for
dr. Billy and me I just want to know you
know how how I'm supposed to keep
strength and peace in my life in this
season I'm I'm a single mom with a
two-year-old and I just found out two
weeks ago that I'm pregnant again and I
just feel a lot of fear and anxiety I'm
gonna employed and I really I'm new to
believing and God and I'm just trying to
like stay sane there's no one in my
trust and it's very hard in the seasons
of my life I can imagine how far along
are you
about eight weeks I just found out and
all that so these are clothes I can't
get into an appointment at this good 19
absolutely so who do you have in your
life that you can lean on or talk to or
text or call or FaceTime with I often we
talk around here that your community the
people that you rely on in these moments
when you find yourself the water rising
around you that's you're at your human
emergency fund that's your life
emergency fund you have a crew that you
can reach out to the disappointment of
the family and everybody around me in
Michigan is like very toxic I don't have
any godly influences in my life
understand I tell you what honey you
hold on a second we'll come back to this
break we'll keep talking okay we're
talking with Alexis in Michigan Alexis
what city are you in in Michigan battle
creek battle creek okay down down South
Michigan then right
okay cool how old are you Alexis 2020
and so here's and your family is located
where you porta in Florida okay but but
they have kind of pushed you to the side
you said before the break and so you've
got a baby on the way you've got a
two-year-old you've lost your job and
you are a new person in your faith is
that what you told us yes okay and
you're 20 years old what were you doing
what was your job I was working at a
window manufacturing company as a
executive customer service
representative and they just laid
everyone off because of the Krone of our
shutdown their company actually it is
shut down probably about a month before
this happened and I'm just an inner
little find a jobs man so now with this
Cove in nineteen is just super hard know
what is what um did you what brought you
to Battle Creek so I actually just moved
Frank Florida me finding out I was
pregnant moved me up here because I
didn't want to be a single mom of two
and their dad is in Michigan his dad
plugged in same dad no it's not
what brought you I battle creek well
that's my aim stays up there are you up
there or not I'm I'm actually I'm on the
way yeah yeah I'm on the way I'm in
Indiana right now oh my god okay alright
so you're going to see you do have an
aunt there then that is supportive yes
or no she's she's on drugs so it's kind
of hard to have that you know godly
influence in my life absolutely okay all
right well well there's two things that
sound like they're in the crisis three
things it sound like they're in crisis
mode to me
one is as quickly as you can get an
appointment with it will be obviously
that's that's number one number two is
you need a job and there are lots of
people hiring for instance grocery
stores
almost all of them are hiring right now
Amazon is hiring for deliveries pizzas
bit deliveries I don't know what you're
doing with the two-year-old while you're
doing all that I don't know what you
were planning to do with the two euro
while you're working anyway you've got
to work that through and then I think
most importantly what John was saying
earlier you've got to get into some
community so immediately upon getting up
there I want you to find a really good
church to plug into and get in touch
with the pastor of that church or the
councillors at that church and let them
know your situation so they can come
around you and walk with you through
this time of unemployment and another
baby on the way and this huge time of
transition you've just got to have some
protection we all do at different times
of our lives and this is the time where
you need help
John what am I missing right I think the
most important thing Dave you just
nailed it all those the big picture
things I think you're gonna feel some
control if you can sit down with a piece
of paper maybe when you stop to get
something to eat this afternoon or this
evening and sit down with a piece of
paper and write out your plan and like
Dave said you've got to protect your
kids you've got to protect your
relationships and if I was you I'd be on
the phone with the health services of
Battle Creek I'd be on the phone with a
local church and getting plugged in to
meet somebody face to face and say what
are your resources and you plugged into
a group because you cannot do this by
yourself yeah you're gonna you're going
to I mean you've got money shortage
you've got relationship shortage you've
got an income shortage and so you know
all of those resources and the good news
is this if you plug into a decent Church
they're gonna do a great job of loving
you and they're not perfect believe me
imperfect people are all that are in
churches and there's no perfect people
there I never met one there but but but
they will they will try to help in some
way and you began to gather that up not
that your take advantage of them or
something like that but you just got to
get some margin you've got no
everything's on razor edge with you
every single thing is on razor edge
you've got to get some some margin some
room some wiggle room in a couple of
these categories that are just wearing
you out the childcare category the
health category the income category the
food
in shelter categories you got a lot of
stuff on you right now and so so make
sure you're not just running from
something that you are running to
something and so if you need some more
help you call us back any time kiddo
call anytime open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
you know John occurs to me I never want
someone to be put in a highly volatile
highly toxic situation but there's at
least some possibility she might need to
go back to her parents in Florida
absolutely if there's any redeemable
part of that relationship I know there's
a lot of shame involved a lot of
condemnation involved obviously some
harsh words have been said but if your
best shot is your aunt who's on drugs in
a town you've never been to it's not a
good shot it's not a good shot that's
bothering me because everything they're
strange
there's no familiarity there's no
nothing and so the devil that you know
might be better and I always recommend
folks if you're if there's physical harm
if someone's gonna get hurt yeah don't
go back there if it's because they want
you to live by their rules under their
house or they have some restriction on
the car you borrow or things like that
then this is I think all of us are
having to look in the mirror and make
some changes about how we operate and
the though I want to are gonna have to
be overshadowed by that I have to s and
I need to use right now yeah yeah yeah
you're not a 42 year old that's been
living life a long time you're a 20 year
old and that's scaring me right yes
that's basically a teenager raising two
yeah two beautiful babies that's right
hey thanks for the call kiddo
if we can help you call back anytime
help be honored to be in your corner and
fight for you